game of the day came in new orleans in
the superdome
the chiefs and the saints got together
you saw the little piece of drew brees
talking about
the fact that he returned to action just
five weeks after
suffering 11 fractured ribs a collapsed
lung j
glazer of fox spoke to brees on saturday
bree
said he wasn't 100 and he couldn't get
another scan to see how
healed his ribs were or weren't because
of concerns that he's been bombarded
with too much radiation and possibly
could become
the incredible hulk if he continued to
bombard himself with radiation
because he'd already had three scans of
his torso
previously so they didn't know
how healed the ribs were he was going
based on how he feels he's not a hundred
percent as he admitted
and it looked that way and chris this is
the basic analysis
starting quarterback backup quarterback
what percentage are you willing to
tolerate below 100 of your starter
before you go with a 100 percent backup
and taysom hill has played well i'm
stunned frankly that they went with
brees because the
eyeball test says the guy's not right
yeah they almost won but the eyeball
test says
the guy's not right they almost won
because
their defense did enough to hold down
that chief's attack their offense did
what their offense normally would do
score points i just i'm surprised that
sean payton who
is a genius of geniuses would allow drew
brees to by all appearances kind of
muscle his way back onto the field
yeah well agreed and the offense wasn't
what it always is right i mean let's not
forget they got a safety they got a
short field
you know score at one point too that
helped out their football team
but i think the point is like the first
thing you said mike i mean
first off it didn't look like he was
comfortable being out there
let alone like what he looked to us like
as a football player because that was
less than no there's no doubt about it
but at no point during the game did you
ever feel like
he felt comfortable in the pocket making
throws making decisions
i mean some of the early throws
decisions and even
sacks there was a lot of double clutch
am i seeing what i think i'm seeing
should i throw it should i pull the
trigger
you know should i move in the pocket so
yeah from that standpoint alone
he did not look comfortable and he did
not play well
and because of that even though the
chiefs weren't playing great like
you knew i don't know i never felt like
the chiefs were in danger of losing the
football game because of that i
i that that was a big aspect of the game
and you know i think you bring up a big
a good question
you know it's sean payton's in a really
tough spot there you got
a legend you know first ballot hall of
famer who says he wants to play
what do you do there i don't know that's
really tough but obviously he wasn't
close to 100
i don't think he was really at 90
percent and
you know in a lot of ways that really
affected their football team and some
big moments there's no doubt
and now you gotta turn it around and
play another game on friday i mean what
do you do
this week when it's clear the guy is
less than a hundred percent you're to
have people in the locker room that are
giving the head coach the side eye
thinking
why are we going with a diminished
physically
41 year old quarterback when we all saw
we all witnessed we all felt what it was
like when he was out there and he didn't
feel comfortable and it was obviously
didn't feel comfortable
he had five incomplete passes to start
the game
i think it was six he had never been
owen six that's what it was owen six
before
in his career to start a game he had an
interception among those first six
passes
and he should have had another one his
first throw of the game
was picked off by daniel sorensen
until a teammate collided with him and
knocked out right and on the broadcast
it's like they didn't even notice it
they barely
gave in it's like dude the first throw
into double coverage
and he's lucky it was double coverage
because it was single coverage it was
getting intercepted by the guy who was
right there to get the ball i mean that
was the first clue that something's not
right
it got worse then it got better but but
this is the chiefs you can't have
your starting quarterback at less than
100 and expect
to outscore the kansas city chiefs
period no
you cannot you know even the chiefs on a
day where
in a lot of ways the saints beat their
butts in a lot of areas i mean we saw
patrick mahomes
under about as much pressure and get hit
as much as i've seen him hit in his
career to this point
you know it was a day where yeah he made
magic but he didn't make magic happen
nearly as often as we're used to seeing
i mean the saints defense did some good
things
you know like you said it was there for
the taking
it was as far as how they match up with
them and
you know catching the chiefs but their
offense
needed to be play an a effort or you
know an a-minus type of football game
and realistically i think if we sat here
and created the saints offense and
breeze and everything together
no that was a a c effort a c plus effort
really and the statistics were brilliant
yeah
plus but but mike i don't know
like really though what do you do if
you're sean payton
what do you do there okay drew brees
comes
to you and says monday i think i can
play this week i want to play
i want to play hey drew where do you
think you're at well i don't know i can
throw
i'm not a hundred percent you know which
basically means i'm not even really
90 either but where where do you go with
that
you know i like it's like coach dungey
you said on the show last night
you know when your stud your star your
ace comes you like that
as a coach you got to just kind of trust
them and ride with it and i i don't know
if you're
you know you're in a no-win situation if
you're sean payton there really
you study film i study people yeah i
study facial expressions i study
demeanors i study
the way the words are delivered so let's
study
shall we sean payton after the game
discussing the performance of drew brees
offensively we didn't start real well
and so it's hard to just
obviously you can point to one position
but
i felt like our third down numbers
weren't good enough today
um i didn't feel like we ran the ball uh
efficiently when we tried um you know
give kansas city credit
we battled back in the game but
you've got to be better on third down
and when you're not you don't have those
attempts you don't have the the snaps
the time of possession all the things
you need
against a good offense like that you
know we talk about time of possession
in a game like this and that that
includes converting third down so
overall offensively we weren't very
sharp
so it was spread around it wasn't
focused on drew brees and this
question this core question fundamental
question with the game looming in just
four
days the saints don't have a short week
game this year per se they didn't have a
thursday turnaround they had a friday
turnaround so they get a little more
time than they would have
right if they had played this game on
thursday but i don't know if that one
day is going to make a difference and
we don't know what kind of additional
damage
drew brees may have done just out there
moving around and whether to what extent
he got banged around it's not like it
took a big hit that had anyone saying oh
my god he's not going to get up
but this really will be a challenge for
sean payton the one thing we know
is that no one will know exactly where
they're going to go
on friday until we get closer to friday
because sean payton has indeed mastered
the very delicate difficult art of
getting everyone to shut the
f up when it comes to who the
quarterback is going to be we saw it
with the taysom hill jameis winston
questioned five weeks ago
and then last week peyton himself on
wednesday
and you know what he didn't know how
right he was when he told reporters that
drew brees still has a ways to go
yes he does but at the same time brees
was taking all of the first okay
reps on wednesday thursday and friday
that that
is like that to me i i thought about
that last night
see that that to me is where and i don't
remember the timing of last week but
just real quick like did he say that
before practice
you know was that a wednesday morning
press conference i couldn't remember
that
specifically either because that comment
was made
in such a way where i i just
it's it was i don't know i mean he guess
he's a good liar a good bser if that's
that's the case if that was the plan all
along
but i i just felt like it was such a no
he's not quite there yet
you know did drew brees come in and go
wait no no i am there yet i'm gonna play
this week i mean did that happen
or was this the okie doke the whole time
you know that was the okie dokie
all right well there's no way i think
drew's going to be playing no
well and and uh i think it was ian
rappaport yesterday that
that made the okie doke 100 clear to the
extent the report is accurate i'm not
saying it isn't but
we're taking the leap of faith here uh
but i've given the benefit of the doubt
that this was the plan all along as of
monday the plan was
he's getting the practice reps all week
he's the guy period end of statement
that's
it right and it was just a day before
monday that jay glazer of fox
said that the christmas day game against
the vikings is the more
likely target for return and i guarantee
you glazer got that straight from peyton
yeah
so i agree with that uh sorry jay jay
doesn't like it when
when we say those things it's it's 4 11
in the morning in the west coast don't
anyone tell him that i said that and
hopefully he won't watch tweet adam
everybody
do it now but but uh because he will fly
here he will fly here and
the what the first day i met let me just
tell you
a story i probably i don't know if i
ever told you this before the first i
ever met the guy was
early 2009 in tampa super bowl week
and he walks up to me and he put his
thumb
right in this spot on your throat yeah i
know right it's a wrestling thing
yeah and he pushed and he pressed it in
and and i like couldn't breathe for two
minutes
so that was my answer i like this story
without any without any reason to
to upset him so if he's upset i'm
getting more than the thumb in the
trachea
yeah well i don't tell him i said that
hey glazers california ufc
tough you're just west virginia soft
what can we say i don't know
but but but anyway but anyway peyton
pulled it off
last week and you're right is is it not
gonna is it not gonna be breeze i mean
yanking breeze for him yeah that's right
there's no way this week would be
a thousand times worse than never
letting him back on the field in the
first place
i i think so in a lot of ways i mean it
just it would won it would go it'd
almost
shine a light on the situation like you
shouldn't have played drew you were
selfish from wanting to play
you know now it was that bad and you're
banged up to
you know we want to take you out once
again you know either way listen it was
a tough situation
they battled as they always do the new
orleans saints
you know two they'll be able to sell to
their football team
if they do play in the super bowl and
match up again that hey we weren't at
our 100 drew wasn't at 100
and look we still only lost by three
points
so in that aspect too there was no
belief loss that they like don't belong
in the field with them or anything like
that
but you know within all this too you
know we we talk about
of course the the chiefs offense and
everything they do
on a weekly basis got to give the the
chief defense a little credit in the
game
with what they did yesterday i mean you
talked about some of the dropped
interceptions
you know breeze's stats are a little
misleading 15 for 34 really wasn't as
good as what it actually
was it was worse than that you know
there was probably what legitimately
four in your both your hands dropped
interceptions tyrone matthew had the one
in the end zone
right that he dropped but their
play-making
and the big thing is to me with kansas
city mike they played a game where they
said no no
we're gonna stop the run drew brees
you're gonna have to beat us that's what
they did
i mean that was the game plan there's no
other way around it it was
stop alvin kamara stop the run drew
brees can you beat us in the pass game
and of course drew was not up to that
task yesterday but we've seen kansas
city
that d even though they're middle of the
league average man when you ask them to
rise up to the occasion
stop the titans and derrick henry in the
afc championship stop
shanahan and you know garoppolo and all
the running they do in the super bowl
and now you know a game yesterday it
just shows you they're
they have some championship caliber
aspects about them where they can rise
to the occasion and
and be physical and beat the best
offenses up in football a little bit
you know 15 for 34 i thought you
misspoke 15 for 34
right that is according to pete
demilitis the lowest completion
percentage for drew brees
since 2006 it's 44 44
stunk in the 70s 44
nowadays when the bar is 70 percent
right you're doing great if you're 70
and if you're above 70 you're awesome
44 is is and and it's
look the passer rating formula i i like
it because it
goes back years and it's apples to
happen how do you get an
84. and 84 now again 84 used to be not a
horrible number nowadays 84 is kind of
like man you stink
but uh you got an 84 rating and 44
passer rating three touchdowns
touchdowns
and and only one interception like you
said dropped interceptions don't show up
on the stat sheet for the quarterback
that's more next level analysis
and uh the bottom line is drew brees was
not drew brees yesterday and
uh but for a heroic effort by the
defense to take some of the steam out of
patrick mahomes now they didn't take any
steam out of the running game you saw
that number 179 awesome
and and they got shredded the week
before by the eagle so
credit to the chiefs to pivot to an
obvious weakness that emerged
based on that game against the eagles
that's i mean the chiefs
you know malleable that way wow big word
for me on a monday morning
but but amazing though you know just
another thing here
where oh hey it's kind of been a
defensive we need to run the ball
play an ugly type of football game no
problem
okay no big issue you know that to me is
the other thing that
is just dangerous about the chiefs i
know we i feel like we say this every
week
but they still haven't played their best
game i don't even think they played
close to their best game
i mean yesterday i really think the
chiefs played a b a b
game for what they're capable of doing
you know all in all
but it just showed on the road hey we
got to do it with our defense and run
the ball well we could do
that way too it's just amazing how they
do it
it really is and uh there's there's a
toughness and just a
belief within their football team um but
i will say this
i over the last few weeks am concerned
about the the lack of pass protection
for patrick mahomes i said this on my
podcast last week where
i wrote you know there's too many times
in my notes here lately i'm writing
you know bad pass bro mahomes avoids it
you know we get we sometimes forget
about how bad the pass protection is
because
he just makes it look so easy how he
weaves and goes and in and out and then
oh boom and there's a 40 yard pass and
we just we forget he was under duress
and he made a 40-yard throw to the
receiver
but it's about this is three or four
weeks in a row now where
it's a little concerning it's a little
much mike how many times did they run
sprint plays yesterday right to sprint
right sprint left
all of that that was because andy reid
had no faith in their ability to block
the the pass rush with the saints so
that's a little concerning for the
chiefs as we go down the stretch here
we heard from sean payton earlier let's
hear from patrick mahomes on winning
close games and at the tail end a little
andy reed on the team's offensive line
here they are
you got to be able to win games in this
league i mean that's that's that's it at
the end of the day
i mean it looks cool and it feels
awesome to win by 20 30 points
but when you have a team that can find a
way to win with their offensive defense
and special teams
um every single game and find a way to
win no matter what the score is
those are the teams that make runs at
the end of the year listen we score
points
and um against a good defensive front i
mean you're talking about one of the
best defensive
if not the best right there so
statistically
and and um you know i thought we ran the
ball efficiently especially the second
half
and uh we we threw the ball
uh well and with the exception of a
couple blitzes they had we they got us
on the one
at the end there but we were pretty
clean um
for the most part you know there were a
couple where they got the quarterback
but
fairly clean
you know you're right chris we're so
accustomed to seeing patrick mahomes run
around he's buying
time with his feet he's making the
offensive line look better
because even if the protection collapses
he knows how to get away from them
we saw a big hit yesterday applied to
mahomes it created a fumble and a short
field for the saints
when the game was still in doubt and it
helped make it a little more interesting
i mean it was 29 to 15.
and it just felt like well it didn't
feel like it it was
the the truth it was one moment away
from it being a blowout yeah that's what
it felt like
15. yeah yeah i'm with you but i mean
this is it's commonplace that's why the
chiefs are frustrating i just feel like
we've said this you know
probably five six weeks in a row where
you go man they're one drive or two
plays away
from just blowing this team off the
field
and they let them hang around but you
know that's a little concerning
listen he's capable of overcoming you
know
pass rush we know that but the way it's
been the last few weeks
i i you know no i think they're playing
with fire a little bit
you know the good thing is like he said
they ran the football they did things
like that they were patient
i mean when have we seen the the chiefs
yesterday
92 offensive plays 4.5 yards per play
that just shows you they were going to
be patient and just take what the
defense gave them and all of that but
uh that's something at least to keep an
eye on down the stretch running game
improving
you know le'veon bell was great but pass
protection and keeping patrick mahomes
clean
you know a little a little scary here at
the end of the season
le'veon bell picked up 62 rushing yards
and a touchdown clyde edwards a lair 79
yards he
had an injury at the end of the game
that looked bad
x-rays were negative that's only part of
the story though until you do an mri you
don't know what damage there may be to
ligaments and tendons and other things
you mentioned the concept of the chiefs
playing with fire
chris the chiefs are the guy at the
circus that juggles
fire and swallows a sword that's on fire
i mean they
live in fire i they thrive in it
they do look at last year in the
playoffs you got to spot the other team
a 10 point lead
before the chiefs even wake up and
they're so used to it and part of it is
the psychology on the other sideline
they know when they see that red helmet
with the arrowhead on the side and the
kc in it that
that no lead is safe and the chiefs are
going to find a way
and when the game is on the line it's
going to be 15
running around hair literally on fire
sidearm pass something spectacular
that's just going to completely deflate
you
and defeat you and that's the way they
are
and until somebody breaks that now can
the bills break that
maybe they can yeah the steelers break
that maybe they can can the ravens break
that
maybe they can we'll find out in january
no
i mean mike you're right uh you know
again
that's i'm not picking against them i
know that i'm not
i mean there's just not any team in
football i'm not taking the chiefs and
patrick from home and company i mean
really you know all that needs to be
said just
to your point you know they've they've
won they've won at baltimore they beat
the patriots they've beaten buffalo
they've beaten the raiders they've
beaten the buccaneers the dolphins on
the road the saints on the road i mean
the resume is really phenomenal i mean
you can't really argue it it's not like
they
squeaked by and oh hey we're 13-1 and we
got one of those lucky years where the
schedule fell right and we've played a
lot of crappy
teams for some reason no they played
like some of the best teams in football
it just doesn't matter
you're right mike i mean i i it's just
frustrating because i want to see
that a or a plus game to see what they
can be
you know at their ultimate because i
just think it's it could be scary good
and fun to watch uh but i don't know you
know it's like a good tease i guess it
keeps me wanting more and more and
tuning in every week
after they won the game last night i
posted this question on twitter chiefs
or the field for super bowl champion i
just retweeted it nineteen thousand
votes so far
fifty six point two percent the field
the chiefs yeah
i mean point eight take the field yeah
and and look
for me it's it's chiefs versus the field
give me chiefs to get to the super bowl
and when you look at the nfc it's
you look i i hate to agree with your
initial take from back in september
the chiefs were gonna repeat but but
there's no one out there that i think
can rise up and do it now if they do
great great story awesome but the chiefs
have set a standard that no one can
match we saw the raiders catch them
napping 40 to 32. it takes 40 points to
beat them
right they scored 32 against the raiders
they scored 32 against the saints
you got to score more than 32. you got
to get 35 or more you got to get 40 if
you're gonna have a chance to beat the
kansas city chiefs that's just the way
it is
yeah and who's able to do that in
january for now there's not a belief
that anyone
is going to be able to pull that off
steve kornacki's playoff picture from
last night the chiefs
clearly the one seed i i they're not
going to blow the ones he's not clinched
yet they're not going to blow the one
seed
the the saints have blown the one seed
over the last two weeks they've lost two
in a row
the packers keep winning it's not over
yet
but the the green bay magic number is
one
right to have the number one seed
they've got the titans on sunday night
which will not be easy and then they've
got the bears
to finish the season which may not be
easy no hey my bears are
my bears are you're firing solid yeah
they're playing good football i mean
their their
offenses turn the corner it's amazing
the change they've made the last few
weeks so yeah that's not going to be
you know any guarantee for the packers
but but it is looking much better for
the packers than it was just a couple of
weeks ago when they trailed the saints
by a game
in that race for the number one seed and
obviously this year the number one seed
means
you're the only team per conference to
get the bye week and then the road to
the super bowl as it always does will go
through your stadium
which may not mean as much this year but
it still means something
lambeau field versus superdome in
january that means something and there
it is green bay's chances now
76 the saints actually have a lower
chance than the seahawks
for the number one seed seahawks at 15
their chances jumped 10
yesterday new orleans plummeted from 21
to 8 the packers
without playing on sunday in great great
shape
to be the number one seed hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports